most colleges are despicable places
today despicable
they teach sick doctrines
babies teach babies at our universities
if I hear you're a professor of gender
studies I assume you're a fool if I hear
you're an epidemiologist I assume you're
a fool do you know what epidemiologists
did to the world with the lockdowns do
you know the damage they did to kids
epidemiologists telling Public Health
officials telling people to keep schools
closed for two years when kids had
essentially no danger from covid do you
know the damage that the these so-called
experts did the kids why aren't parents
angry at these people why do they still
believe in quote-unquote experts
Sweden closed down nothing it has the
lowest excess death rate of the last two
years on Earth
no kid got covered and they kept the
schools open until the age of 16.
Sweden shamed the rest of the world in
staying open thank God for Sweden it was
our it was our litmus test
people it is very hard it's hard for me
I went to Columbia University graduate
school and and I remember if you were a
professor of History I almost shook
because I thought wow what a I'm meeting
someone who has mastered
such a great discipline of history or
professor of English or whatever
but now if I hear you're a professor I
assume you're a fool not all professors
are full I just make that assumption wow
Guilty By Association no not by
association by Title by profession it's
not because they're associating with
other fools do you know that uh I think
her name is Amy wax a professor at the
University of Pennsylvania Law School
ivy league law school she wrote a column
with another professor saying you know
what middle class Bourgeois values are
great values basically as follows that
you uh you graduate high school you get
a job you get married and then have
children after you get married those are
the four things and you'll be a winner
in this Society basically if you just do
those four things
just for writing that 250 law professors
at the University of Pennsylvania asked
the university to not allow her to teach
the introductory course she was teaching
she's been ostracized by fellow lawyers
because all she affirmed was
middle-class values which they call now
of course white supremacist values which
of course is an insult to non-whites oh
I see only whites should graduate high
school get a job get married and then
have children blacks should not do that
the only systemic racism in America is
from the left they believe in separate
graduations for blacks separate
dormitories for blacks they believe that
it is wrong to be race blind they
believe race tells me something about
you so I have a great question if race
is important what do you know about a
person if you know he or she is black
name me one thing you know about that
person
after all it's supposedly a very
important aspect the most important
aspect according to the morons who teach
at colleges
you know maybe nothing nothing
you know nothing if you know someone is
white you know nothing if someone is
anything right it means nothing
MLK yesterday yes Emily exactly
skin colors is is less important than
shoe color
if your shoes don't match your outfit
especially for a woman it matters
yeah but your your skin color doesn't
mean a damn thing so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]